bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'obsolescence programmée alors déjà
parlé il ya pas longtemps dans une
précédente vidéo concernant apple et
l'obsolescence programmée mais ça
continue il ya des nouvelles infos donc
on va en parler là plein de choses à
voir et ça on va le regarder maintenant
[Musique]
dont l'obsolescence programmée c'est
encore en cours en 2018 alors nous
explique il ya quelque temps je vous ai
fait une précédente vidéo pour vous
parler de notre seule chance programmée
par rapport au produit d'apple depuis le
mois de décembre 2010 est apple et a été
attaqué en justice pour obsolescence
programmée alors effectivement c'était
un petit peu compliqué parce que apple a
reconnu réduit à la performance de ses
smartphones pour préserver la batterie
enfin il ya eu plein de choses dessus
d'ailleurs je vous invite si vous voulez
remettre un petit peu tous en mémoire à
regarder la vidéo qui est ici on apprend
pas mal de choses et justement ça
continue et on va regarder aujourd'hui
quatre choses ensemble numéro un la
première chose c'est que effectivement
apple a reconnu [ __ ] certains de ses
smartphones de part son os mais par
contre a complètement assuré ne pas du
tout brider ses ipad apple watch et mac
donc si vous êtes comme moi possesseurs
de plusieurs produits chez apple soit de
l'ipad de l'aouach ou du mac macbook pro
autre mac vous pouvez tranquille parce
que les batteries de ces produits sont
assez performante assez grosse pour la
roche
j'ai toujours en nous mais bon a priori
a pas de problème ces batteries seraient
assez grosses pour pouvoir effectivement
encaissés les pic de performance
à la différence des iphone qui eux ne le
peuvent pas donc c'est la raison de ce
bridage donc ça c'est le premier point
numéro 2 deuxième point maintenant vous
avez jusqu'au 31 décembre 2018 pour
remplacer vos batteries au prix de 29
euros contre 89 euros alors ça concerne
pas tous les iphone ça concerne les
iphone 6 6 + 6 aces 6 ess +77 +88 plus
et iphone 10 ce sont les iphone 5 ces
cinq pièces les 4 ou lorsqu'il y en a
qui ont encore d'autres modèles et bien
non vous ne pourrez pas mais a priori de
toute façon les anciens modèles sont pas
pacte et par les mises à jour parce que
ça serait une mise à jour d'ios 11 et
les modèles plus anciens peuvent pas
être mises à jour soient alloués sont
donc vous êtes tranquille
troisième point la future mise à jour à
venir de ayo et 11 vous permettra
effectivement d'avoir le choix soit vous
pourrait brider vos iphone pour limiter
les pics de performance et éviter
effectivement votre téléphone ne
s'éteigne tout seul soit vous pourrez
faire le choix de ne pas l'activer et à
ce moment là si votre téléphone
surchauffe
s'il ya des pics de performance le
smartphone pourra s'éteindre parce ça
c'est un peu le risque
le côté positif c'est que apple
maintenant vous avertis vous laisse le
choix de brider ou de ne pas brider et
maintenant du coup il ya un vrai
transfert de responsabilités sur vous
vous êtes informés vous savez comment ça
se passe si vous voulez pas leurs idées
c'est vous qui prenez le risque c'est
votre problème et c'est votre
responsabilité
ça ça pose quand même un petit problème
est ce que apple ne pourrait pas quand
ils vendent des produits neufs marqué
tout simplement la batterie de
smartphones ne pourra durer que un an
deux ans trois ans peu importe
sinon après vous allez devoir l'abri des
houles a changé à tel tarif
voilà ça c'est aussi un petit peu love
la formation qu'on pourrait donner dès
le départ quand on va acheter un produit
chez apple ou chez un autre d'ailleurs
numéro quatre quatrième point samsung
est également visé par une enquête pour
obsolescence programmée
c'est pas en france c'est en italie
c'est l'autorité de la concurrence
italienne qui s'appelle la up j'ai le
nom ici excusez mon accent jeu très très
bon italien autorités à garantir des la
concurence à et l mercato en gros c'est
la gcm l'autorité indépendante qui
également ap autorités anti trust qui a
ouvert une enquête contre le géant de
l'électronique samsung et contre apple
également pour obsolescence programmée
les deux groupes sont soupçonnés d'avoir
mis en place une politique commerciale
générale visant à exploiter les carences
de certains composants pour réduire le
temps de prestations de leurs produits
afin d'inciter le consommateur à acheter
de nouvelles versions boîte donc c'est
très clairement la définition de
l'obsolescence programmée
il faut savoir ces enquêtes elles font
suite à différentes plaintes de
consommateurs en italie et qui vise
aussi les mises à jour proposées aux
clients sans signaler les conséquences
possibles de ces mises à jour ni fournir
suffisamment d'informations sur la
manière de maintenir un niveau adéquat
de prédation des dispositifs selon
antitrust c'est la violation du code du
commerce italien tout simplement
l'autorité a déjà mené avec la police
financière des inspections aux sièges
des deux groupes apple et samsung en
italie savait très bien ce qui se passe
et 14h45 vous madame vous êtes tenace en
garde à vous en garde à vue en france le
parquet avait ouvert le 5 janvier une
enquête préliminaire pour obsolescence
programmée et tromperie contre apple
alors pour l'instant france il ya rien
d'autre contre samsung
c'est ce n'est c'est ce n'est une
plainte déposée par deux ong pour
pratiques commerciales trompeuses
accusant le géant sud-coréen d'employer
des enfants et d'imposer des conditions
de travail et des logements indignes à
ses salariés en chine
[Applaudissements]
samsung a réagi dans un communiqué
affirmant appliquer et exigeait de ses
fournisseurs une tolérance zéro
vis-à-vis du travail des enfants
les enquêtes nous dirons la suite et on
verra ce qu'il en sortira quant à
l'obsolescence programmée pour samsung
par rapport à l'enquêté ouverte en
italie
samsung a réagi en disant que non il ne
faisait pas du tout d'obsolescence
programmée
là où par contre effectivement apple
avait reconnu brider ses smartphones de
toute façon ça fait d'éprouver un parent
geekbench la samsung a dit non nous on
ne fait pas du tout d'obsolescence
programmée
donc on verra effectivement ce que d'en
quête va dire faut savoir qu'à ce jour
il ya 39 à saxon qui ont été faites aux
états unis contre apple
il faut savoir que le 19 janvier les
autorités coréennes ont elles mêmes
lancé leur propre enquête contre apple
pour l'instant on n'a pas plus
d'informations les enquêtes vont prendre
énormément de temps mais en tout cas on
va très très bien qu'il ya un vrai
problème et c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui se dessine en tout cas pour 2018
hier apple
aujourd'hui samsung demain peut-être les
autres l intérêt tout ça c'est
effectivement d'aller dans ce sens du
consommateur de mieux être prémunie
contre tous ces problèmes d'obsolescence
programmée
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle de ses
deux marques bien à d'autres et des
grandes marques d'imprimantes sur lequel
il ya déjà eu des enquêtes par le passé
alors au final quel est l'enjeu des
enquêtes massé savoir si tout simplement
c'est firme apple samsung ou autres font
réellement de l'obsolescence programmée
ce qui est difficile à prouver ces
l'intentionnalité est ce que ces marques
cherchent vraiment délibérément affaires
de l'obsolescence programmée pour vendre
de nouveaux produits les arrêts la
foudre célébrer mon cas la scénographie
l'un ou alors comme le dit apple pour sa
ligne de défense
non pas du tout le but c'est de
préserver de consommateurs de lui
proposer des produits qui vont durer
toujours plus longtemps bridée l'oas
tout simplement pour préserver la
batterie
donc c'est très très compliqué parce que
si on n'arrive pas à prouver le fait que
ces entreprises sociétés cherchent
délibérément à brider leurs produits on
peut pas du tout prouvé qu'elle de
l'obsolescence programmée
on peut être prouvé avec le produit et
une durée de vie trop courte pas pour à
ce qu'on pourrait attendre de lui on
peut pas prouver que la marque a fait
exprès brider les produits maintenant à
voir quelle est la ligne de défense de
samsonite façon il ya une enquête qui
est en cours
on en saura davantage on verra si
effectivement samsung de par des tests a
vraiment brider ses produits s'il ya une
vraie différence de performance entre
les produits neufs et les produits au
bout de
un an deux ans trois ans d'utilisation
le risque c'est quoi dans tout ça alors
je vous ai déjà parlé dans la précédente
vidéo mais c'est important de se
rappeler parce que le risque c'est tout
d'abord la perte de confiance du client
j'ai pas confiance en toi vous êtes
consommateur comme moi si la marque en
laquelle vous avez confiance bride ses
produits et yann l'obsolescence
programmée de toute façon vous n'allez
plus achetés chez eux mêmes de toute
façon dès lors qu'il ya un doute qui a
instauré dans la tête des gens il risque
de perdre des clients
parce que tant que le doute hélas ça
nuit à l'image de marque est le deuxième
point c'est le risque d'amendé
il risque d'y avoir des grosses
pénalités financières pour apple et pour
samsung s'est effectivement ils sont
condamnés
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ses enquêtes sur
l'obsolescence programmée visant apple
visant samsung alors ça reste toujours
très très très délicat il faut prendre
des pincettes
effectivement du côté d'apple on voit
qu'il ya eu des modifications par
rapport à noël par rapport à samsung via
une enquête est ouverte pour l'instant
il était vraiment préserver mais ça fait
pas d'eux des coupables ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre donc voilà on regarde ça un
petit peu distant on va en reparler
régulièrement parce que c'est une chose
hyper important ne serait ce que pour
vous et pour moi aussi par rapport à nos
smartphones mais voilà il faut rester
mesuré et voir un petit peu ce que les
enquêtes vont dire et vont donner en
tout cas ce qui est super intéressant ce
qu'on voit c'est que ça va changer un
peu les choses ça va aller dans le sens
du consommateur et ça va mieux nous
préserver parce que s'il ya énormément
dans quelques îles sont ouvertes à
l'international dans ces cas-là franska
l'italie il ya la corée il ya israël il
ya les états unis il ya énormément de
pays ça va continuer à mon avis à faire
des petits ya sept ans ça va forcément
aller dans notre sens à nous pour mieux
de protéger donc dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous pensez réellement que
société fondée l'obsolescence programmée
c'est super intéressant
il ya déjà eu pas mal des changes sur
les commentaires la précédente vidéo
mais maintenant qu'on est un peu plus
d'information va être dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes client apple
samsung ou autre est-ce que vous pensez
que vous que d'autres marques le fond
est ce que vous pensez que d'autres
marques pourraient le faire on dit pas
que les deux premières le fond mais en
tout cas est ce que vous pensez que
d'autres marques seraient susceptibles
de le faire donc marquer mansat en
commentaire et est ce que en tout cas
vous avez vous remarqué des changements
sur vos smartphones on parle de huawei
on peut parler aussi de au nord on peut
parler d'eux
one plus préparés énormément de marques
donc dites moi si vous avez remarqué des
changements entre le jour où vous avez
acheté votre produit est maintenant un
an deux ans voire trois ans
d'utilisation
donc voilà marquer ma tout ça parce que
c'est hyper intéressant et puis de toute
façon ce qui est passionnant là dedans
c'est d'avoir le retour d'expérience de
tout le monde parce que là on en parle
on parle effectivement de cas on va
effectivement de ce que des personnes
l'ont constaté mais vous qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire merci
beaucoup d'être là toujours plus
nombreux à regarder les vidéos à mettre
des commentaires à partager à mettre des
pousse à vous abonner
vous êtes géniaux je vous aime
énormément mettez-moi tous à vos
commentaires vos pouces vos like
abonnez-vous parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus et toujours mieux du high
tech
je vous remercie d'être là toujours plus
nombreux et avoir encore plus de contenu
je vous réserve plein de belles
surprises pour 2018 donc rester sage
abonnez vous à bientôt
je vous kiffe camp